the child ministry of culture represents
an end to one of the pillars of society is
a direct attack on society
we do not accept the ministry of
culture in the coup government the only people
wants a ministry of health
the democratic government of government
progressive who tried to overthrow the
fear and by the ministry of culture a
new political moment
We are fighting the role of
society
symptomatic is a government that is only
white men insect turkey if not at all
have young do not have blacks
the light woman a government that he is not
legitimate is about racism is so
transphobia is about racism and this
backtracking we will not let
to happen all
Do you have a ministry without women?
has weak Brazilian civil ministry is
much more diverse than the
that this incarcerated minority will create